[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je n'avais plus rien à
réver Je n'avais Plus rien
[Musique]
chanter quand tu es venu m'apporter
toi
l'aventure
[Musique]
j'avais
J'ai organisé maman
Fri j'étais bon pirre et bon Mari
aussi c'était
classé c'était fini
enfin
[Musique]
l'aventure
ouais j'avais le
t
ouais j'avais bisou
c'est bien
Monsieur Je Né cherchais
pas mais j'étais
[Musique]
prt n'importe
quoi et voil qu'un coup de
été
réveillé Au bon
moment Je l'ai mordu en pleine D
ouais
l'aventure sur Ne peut pas tomber
Plus
bas
Je suis souvent rentré chez
Moi avec
l'envie que se voit Sur
Moi
[Musique]
l'aventure et
voilà, j'aimais bien
Sur un
fait semblant de
rien comme s'il
était
naturel que je me
payer un
joujou
pareil
maintenant
tout est comme
Avant mais Je suis rentrer dans le
[Musique]
r et quand j'entends chanter le vent
j'entends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh